hollywood hat diesen verwunschenen ort
wortwörtlich vor dem untergang bewahrt
die abrissbirne stand schon bereit um
ihr kurzen prozess zu machen und
plötzlich steht das filmteam vor der tür
gigantische türme beherrschen eine insel
mit einer dunklen vergangenheit
was machen sie in dieser einöde
eine geheimnisvolle insel mitten in der
ostsee
es ist absolut rätselhaft aller gebäude
sind von einschusslöchern durchsiebt
fast wie in einem kriegsgebiet
seltsame bauten in einer der
gefährlichsten ecken an englands küste
von wales passierte hier unter
ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
der inbegriff von top secret
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
die anlagen aufgegeben manche sind heute
lebensgefährlich verseucht doch wer
waren ihre erbauer wie wurden sie
errichtet und warum wurden sie verlassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mitten im us staat ohio nördlich von
mansfield steht ein beeindruckendes
gebäude
[Musik]
von außen erinnert es an einen palast
oder ein schloss
die architekten es darauf abgesehen mit
dem gebäude eindruck zu schinden
dort einem wird sofort klar dass es eine
wichtige aufgabe zu erfüllen hatte und
das ist die zeit überdauern sollte
es ist nicht nur ausladend sondern auch
aufwendig gestaltet ein echtes statement
mit seiner enorm massiven bauweise ist
es allerdings nicht besonders einladend
es lässt einen schauer über den rücken
laufen und man kann sich gut vorstellen
dass sie etwas schlimmes passiert ist
[Applaus]
die düstere erscheinung ist nur ein
erster hinweis auf die brutale und
wechselhafte geschichte dieses ortes
[Musik]
der ursprüngliche zweck und die spätere
nutzung könnten kaum unterschiedlicher
sein
es ist es sollte um spirituelle
regeneration und wiedergeburt gehen ein
ort des seelenheils geradezu friedlich
die erbauer hätten sich nicht ausmalen
können für welche horrorgeschichten
dieser ort später bekannt werden sollte
wer also hat diese spektakuläre kulisse
erschaffen
wozu hat sie gedient
und warum wurde sie aufgegeben
spätes neunzehnte jahrhundert ein
reformatorischer wind weht durch ohio
als dieses gebäude in der mitte der 1800
80er jahre geplant wird
mansfield hatte man ganz besondere pläne
es ging um eine neue ära des
strafvollzugs liberal und
fortschrittlich
junge straftäter sollten rehabilitiert
umerzogen und auf den rechten weg
gebracht werden
das war neu es ging nicht darum zu
bestrafen sondern beim lernen zu helfen
gefängnis nicht mehr als keimzelle neuer
verbrechen der kreislauf der
kriminalität sollte gestoppt werden
die bauarbeiten ziehen sich über zehn
jahre
1896 kommen die ersten 150 jugendlichen
straftäter in die erziehungsanstalt
beim einzug ist der komplex noch nicht
mal fertig die gefangenen selbst bauen
noch daran zum beispiel an der
kanalisation
wegen fehlender mittel wird das
gefängnis erst 1910 endgültig
fertiggestellt
und jeglicher fortschrittliche ansatz
weicht schnell der sehr brutalen
realität hinter den anstaltsmauern
[Musik]
der alltag stellte sich bald als das
absolute gegenteil da
das muss nach stadt rehabilitation und
besserung wurden die schweren jungs
weggesperrt und der schlüssel quasi
weggeschmissen
[Musik]
diese flügel ist beispielhaft für die
dramatische wende die die einrichtung
letztlich nahm
die schlüsselgewalt hat heute
wir sind hier im zellenblock west wo die
insassen untergebracht waren auf fünf
etagen gibt es 350 zellen die als
einzelzellen geplant waren aber es
wurden direkt zwei häftlinge darin
untergebracht also 700 in diesem blog am
anfang ging das auch noch aber später
waren sie hier 20 22 stunden am tag
weggesperrt
wenn ich mir das vorstelle man läuft
durch diesen gang in die vergitterte
zelle und dann wird die tür hinter einen
zugeknallt und verriegelt und
dann die geradezu animalische
geräuschkulisse durch die mithäftlinge
es muss furchtbar gewesen
die steigende kriminalität beschert dem
ohio state reformator immer neue
insassen bald müssen jugendliche und
erwachsene getrennt werden der
fortschrittliche ansatz ist gescheitert
und die minderjährigen werden in andere
einrichtungen verlegt
es war bald eine anstalt für erwachsene
für die jugendlichen hat man einen
anderen ort gefunden plötzlich war
wieder platz und was macht man mit
lauter leere zellen
mangelte nicht an straftätern die
kriminalitätsrate stieg stetig im ganzen
land waren die gefängnisse überfüllt und
ehe man sich versah war mansfield eines
von ihnen und nicht nur das es wurde
eines der schlimmsten
mann brachte einige der gefährlichsten
schwerverbrecher des landes hierunter
beherbergt über die jahre einige
traurige berühmtheit
darunter george wachsmodell ein mitglied
der gang an john dillinger
reporter heute besser bekannt als der
schriftsteller henry oder doktor sam
shepard der jahrelang fälschlicherweise
für den mord an seiner frau inhaftiert
ist
das gefängnis wird voller und voller und
der alltag wird immer härter und
gefährlicher
irgendwann bricht die disziplin in
mansfield vollends zusammen
[Musik]
die einrichtung wird zum
hochsicherheitsgefängnis umgewidmet
[Musik]
die gewalt war an der tagesordnung
es wurde geprügelt abgestorben oder
jemand wurde von einem der oberen gänge
herunter gestoßen man musste jeden tag
um sein leben fürchten
sobald man an kam bekam man den tipp
sich eine waffe zu organisieren und zu
verstecken also immer etwas spitzes
griffbereit zu haben damit man sich im
falle des falles wenigstens verteidigen
konnte und diese vorsicht war durchaus
geboten
das ende dieser dunklen gänge sollte man
tunlichst vermeiden für den ein oder
anderen werden sie zur endgültigen
sackgasse
die gefährlichsten häftlinge saßen in
einzelhaft das sollte sie leuten hier zu
sein war die größte strafe sie durften
während der ganzen zeit nicht sprechen
das licht brannte mal 24 stunden am
stück mal gar nicht lesen war verboten
es gab keine festgelegte essenszeiten
sie wussten also nie wie spät es war am
anfang hatten sie nicht mehr kleidung
waren also völlig nackt es gab einen
eimer für die notdurft und geschlafen
wurde auf dem betonboden in
einem gefängnis in dem es jeden tag zu
gewaltausbrüchen kommt ist es natürlich
nicht verwunderlich dass das so genannte
noch immer ausgebucht ist
nach einer eskalation sollten sogar mal
120 häftlinge auf einmal ins loch und
das für 30 tage
dabei wurde wohl einen leichnam entdeckt
der schon seit ein paar tagen in einer
matratze vor sich hin monate ehe ihn
jemand vermisste
letztlich sind es die inhaftierten
selbst die ihr schicksal in die hand
nehmen
[Musik]
in metz freunde das ging so lange bis
die häftlinge die einrichtung verklagten
sie sahen ihre konstitutionellen rechte
verletzt und prangerten die
unmenschliche behandlung an mit dem
ergebnis dass das gefängnis 1990 ein für
alle mal geschlossen wurde
während der 96 jahre die das ohio state
reformator ii betrieben wurde waren fast
150.000 kriminelle hier untergebracht
200 von ihnen abends nicht überlebt
ein verfluchter ort und dass es hier
heute noch spukt ist nicht weiter
verwunderlich bedenkt man die
kontinuierliche gewalt die hierfür so
viele jahrzehnte geherrscht hat
da müssen sie nur unsere mitarbeiter
fragen
wie können ihnen geschichten erzählen
welche kommen sie und finden sie es
heraus
[Musik]
dank eines kuriosen umstands ist das
mansfield gefängnis heute eine
schaurig-schöne
touristenattraktion
[Musik]
es sollte eigentlich abgerissen werden
doch dann wurde hier der spätere
blockbuster die verurteilten gedreht
die abrissbirne stand tatsächlich schon
bereit
doch dann stand hollywood vor der tür
die verurteilten haben das gefängnis
also vom todesurteil bewahrt
[Musik]
ganz sie die zweitgrößte britische
kanalinsel
an ihrer küste stehen bizarre bord
ein ruhiger fast idyllischer landstrich
um so mehr stechen diese riesigen
betonteile heraus
die anordnung und die struktur der
objekte wie sie da so herausragen haben
ein bisschen was von den osterinseln
stolz wäre dort star wars gefilmt wurden
dies will die streiks seltsames stelen
die aus dem boden ragen
und dann ist da diese überdimensionierte
betonschüssel
sie ist riesig wie ein amphitheater
die anwohner hätten sich sicher nie
vorstellen können dass hier mal so was
gebaut würde
und unter der schüsse hören die
geheimnisse nicht auf
[Musik]
schienen führen in einen tunnel
und dieser tunnel wiederum führt nach
und nach immer weiter in die tiefe
schaut man sich das mal etwas näher an
erkennt man ein geflecht aus wegen dort
links und rechts davon alte markierungen
ein labyrinth aus dunklen räumen mit
mysteriösen symbolen und schriftzeichen
aber nicht etwa auf englisch es ist
deutsch
ein erster hinweis auf das schicksal der
menschen die hier wirkten
[Musik]
das war echt heftig
wenn ihm viele mussten schrecklich
hungern
aber wer hat das gebaut
und warum wurde es verlassen
[Musik]
die geschichte nimmt ihren anfang in den
ersten jahren des zweiten weltkriegs im
juni 1940 hat hitler frankreich besetzt
und wendet sich nun großbritannien zu
[Musik]
nur etwa 30 kilometer über den
ärmelkanal war das ziel schon zum
greifen nah
[Musik]
aber ein stück britischen territoriums
liegt sogar noch näher die kanalinseln
[Musik]
die britischen kanalinseln liegen
tatsächlich näher an frankreich als ein
großbritannien und für hitler waren sie
strategisch wichtig
in england nach frankreich sind die
inseln wie ein sprungbrett
und das wollten die deutschen nicht
zulassen
sie wollten den briten die kontrolle der
inseln entziehen die so nah vor
frankreichs küsten liegen
am 28 juni 1940 fliegen die deutschen
bombardieren sollen an
[Musik]
mit dem magische weise hatten die
deutschen mit großem widerstand
gerechnet bei dem luftangriff kamen 44
menschen ums leben ein unnötiges
blutvergießen
sei nie weiter als die deutschen ein
paar tage später an landeten wurde ihnen
bewusst dass die inseln gänzlich
ungeschützt gewesen waren
[Musik]
1940 bot großbritannien nazi-deutschland
ganz allein die stirn und churchill
wusste nicht ob er stand halten konnte
geschweige denn die kanalinseln guernsey
jersey sack und orlen ii verteidigen
während der frankreich offensive im
sommer 1940 wurden 30.000 inselbewohner
also fast ein drittel evakuiert der rest
wollte die scheinbar unabwendbare
invasion abwarten
ende juni wird die deutsche flagge
übergossen
[Musik]
am ersten juli kapituliert dass sie die
forderung nach weißen flaggen auf den
häusern ist nur ein vorgeschmack auf das
bevorstehende regiment
[Musik]
während sc-trainer auf ankommen ließ
will hitler eine verteidigungslinie die
alles andere in den schatten stellt
ein teil davon ist dieser
beobachtungspunkt die marine paul stand
und messstellen 3 kurz mp3
[Applaus]
[Musik]
experte und naturschützer paul borger es
erklärt wie er funktioniert
der mp3 bunker war einer von fünf mit
ihm konnte man angreifer auffinden und
beobachten und deren ziel daten an die
gefechts stellungen weiterleiten
die bauarbeiten für die ausladenden
verteidigungsanlagen von görwihl
dauerten über ein jahr
[Musik]
einige kilometer weiter im landesinneren
findet sich dann diese riesige
betonschüssel
[Musik]
doch was hat es damit auf sich
auf diesen gleisen wurde die munition zu
den lagern im bunker gebracht sie
lagerte dann hier in diesem großen raum
also nachdem sie über diese luca herein
kam wurde sie hier aufbewahrt
[Musik]
in diesem bunker system sind 46.000
kubikmeter beton verbaut hier sind die
gruppen quartiere waffenlager und
elektrischen generatoren untergebracht
[Musik]
es sollte auch extremsten angriffen
standhalten
[Musik]
in den tiefen der anlage finden sich
zeugnisse der deutschen und ihrer ziele
[Musik]
hier zb ein deutscher adler an der wand
und
hier
das warten der schiffs ingenieure darauf
der schriftzug dass sie richtung england
marschieren das war ihr motto
wir aufbauen nach england
inversion england zwar ihr erklärtes
ziel
aber warum steht es an der bunker wand
das selbstbewusstsein der deutschen wird
sicher auch durch das waffenarsenal in
der betonschüssel gestärkt
die batterie -
die größte artilleriestellung der
kanalinsel
[Musik]
es gab vier riesige geschützt stellungen
sie waren als häuser getan daran kann
man erahnen wie groß sie waren
hier stand eines der vier 30,5 cm
geschütze
direkt in der mitte auf diesen
metallbolzen
unter dem geschützt war eine riesige
sprengladung angebracht die hätte im
falle einer übernahme die kanone aus der
verankerung reißen können
mit einer reichweite von 50 kilometern
konnten die inseln verteidigt und die
küste der normandie erreicht werden
die deutsche feuerkraft auf ganze war
außergewöhnlich
insgesamt gab es auf der insel 17
solcher artilleriestellungen und 175
luftabwehrgeschütze
aber die kosten waren hoch
es ist portable inseln waren teil des
atlantiks von norwegen spanien und die
insel stellungen machen ungefähr 8
prozent des auf der strecke verbauten
beton aus
auf den kanalinseln gab es durch die
vielen stellungen angeblich mehr
geschützt als auf den 600 kilometern
küstenlinie der normandie
deutsche offiziere die nicht von der
sinnhaftigkeit der anlagen auf den
kanalinseln überzeugt waren nannten
diese extrem ressourcenintensiven
festungsanlagen auch heimlich hitlers
was aber wurde aus der batterie -
nachdem so viel mühe zeit geld und
propaganda hineingesteckt worden
der anfang vom ende war der sechste juni
die alliierten invasion der normandie
[Musik]
allerdings nachdem die day wurden die
deutschen soldaten auf den kanalinseln
von der versorgung abgeschnitten
die pakete des roten kreuzes waren
allein für die britischen einheimischen
die gestrandeten soldaten gingen leer
aus
[Musik]
die truppen bekamen nichts von den
nationen sie verhungerten versuchten sie
vögel zu fangen oder sammelten
abschmecken am strand selbst algen und
seegras wanderten in den topf
auch wenn sie sich den magen verdorben
alles war besser als zu verhungern
nach einem qualvollen jahr des hungers
war auch für die deutschen soldaten auf
göns ii eine minute nach mitternacht am
9 mai 1945 der krieg vorbei
batterie - war geschichte und wanderte
ins altmetall
[Musik]
noch heute bestimmen die nazi bauten als
relikt des dritten reiches jerseys
erscheinungsbild
[Musik]
südfinnland
aus der ostsee ragt eine geheimnisvolle
insel
aus der ferne eine insel wie lieder
andere kommt man aber näher sieht man
den unterschied
gallen ist ja etwas düster ist ein
bisschen gruseliges über der insel
ich würde mich nicht darum reißen dort
allein zu sein
schiffs kompasse spielen ihr verrückt
die strände sind teilweise schwarz
und es wird noch verrückter
[Musik]
bunker ähnliche bauten säumen den strand
rest der alte rohrleitungen liegen
zwischen felsen und beton
das ist keine normale insel
schon seit jahrhunderten gibt das gebiet
um die insel rätsel auf auf kompass ist
ihr kein verlassen
und gesunkene schiffe häufen sich vor
der küste
außerdem schiffswracks unter wasser
finden sich seltsame ruinen an land
einschusslöcher und sprengkraft zieren
die wände dagegen gleicht einem
kriegsgebiet
doch wie fängt alles an
drehen wir die zeit zurück es ist 1809
das gros fürstentum finnland wird
autonome bestandteil des russischen
zarenreichs und ein teil davon ist
strategisch besonders wichtig die insel
llosa
[Musik]
der süden finnlands spielt für russland
eine große rolle hier ist das
einfallstor nach sankt petersburg
sie haben ein großes interesse daran den
finnischen meerbusen zu kontrollieren
sie liegt mitten drin wer nach helsinki
oder den hafen von sankt petersburg will
muss ein user vorbei das macht die insel
aus militärischer sicht enorm wertvoll
die gegend hat aber auch ihre tücken
[Musik]
während der eiszeiten war sie von
kilometer dickem eis bedeckt und
runtergedrückt seit das eis geschmolzen
ist hebt sich die insel um 4 mm pro jahr
die wiege die vor 50 jahren noch frei
lagen sind heute vielleicht durch
felsige inseln blockiert
[Musik]
russland errichtet hier einen
außenposten um schiffe sicher durch die
gewässer nach sankt petersburg zu leiten
aber was für überbleibsel sind noch über
die insel verteilt
russland hat ein noch viel tiefer gehen
das interesse an just
60 liegt hier das größte unter wasser
eisenerzvorkommen finnlands
und damit ist aufgeklärt warum die
kompasse in dieser gegend ihren dienst
versagen
kommt der pluspol des kompasses wird vom
minuspol der erde dem nordpol angezogen
aber hier reagiert der magnet des
kompasses viel stärker auf das
magnetfeld der umgebung als auf den
nordpol
in den 1800 40ern schickt man russische
gefangene nach jossa und zwingt sie zur
arbeit in den minen
[Musik]
die arbeiter schlugen sich mit langen
hand metall bohren und hämmern
zentimeter für zentimeter durch den fels
die bedingungen waren so katastrophal
dass die arbeitslager in sibirien
angeblich erstrebenswerter waren
der eisenerzabbau ist bereits
eingestellt als finnland 1917 seine
unabhängigkeit von russland erklärt die
nächsten jahrzehnte sind zwischen den
ungleichen nachbarn extrem
spannungsgeladen
1939 recht zwischen den beiden der
winter krieg um die karelische land
enger aus
die bedingungen sind furchtbar bei minus
34 grad celsius kämpft das kleinere und
schwächere finnland erbittert um jeden
zentimeter
hain vorteile bieten tiefer schnee
dichte bilder und kurze tage
im märz 1940 wird der krieg mit dem
friedensvertrag von moskau beendet zwar
muss finnland beträchtliche teile seines
gebietes abtreten kann aber seine
unabhängigkeit bewahren
manche sagen dieser schlag für russland
hätte hitler ermutigt ein jahr später in
russland einzumarschieren
1950 hat sich finnland zwischen den ost
und west mächten recht gut eingerichtet
und nimmt trotz anhaltender spannungen
den eisenerzabbau wieder auf
die bienen werden nun mit neuen und
modernen maschinen und in wesentlich
größerem stil beteiligen
breunings torte die minenbetreiber
errichteten eine völlig neue
infrastruktur mit steinbruch maschinen
unter wasser gleisen und rohrsystemen an
land die tannine warf jetzt eine menge
gewinn ab
[Musik]
damals zog auch heranwächst römer auf
die insel
[Musik]
der tunnel verlief über diese ganze
strecke also direkt von dem schacht da
oben bis runter auf 170 meter da draußen
in den stollen
alles in allem 1 3 kilometer tunnel
system das bis fast 200 meter in die
tiefe ging
aber auch diesmal findet der
eisenerzabbau ein ende
die eisen preise sinken weltweit und so
auch die profite die mine wird
geschlossen und die kumpel fahren zum
letzten mal ein
weihnachten 1967 hat man den
minenarbeitern mitgeteilt dass schluss
ist
und mit dem ende des abbaus wurde auch
das minengelände sich selbst überlassen
die zerstörungen sind nicht zu übersehen
und es ist eindeutig dass das nicht
allein wind und wetter gewesen sein
können
nachdem die kumpel weg waren kam die
finisher armee die insel war strategisch
einfach zu wichtig um sie allein zu
lassen
in den 60er 70er und 80er jahren ging
von der sowjetunion eine reale gefahr
aus
die finnen waren durchaus aufmerksam und
beobachteten die russen genau
aber die insel wurde vor allem für
militärische ausbildung und manöver
genutzt hier konnten sie recht gefahrlos
scharfe munition und bombenabwürfe
testen ohne zivilisten in gefahr zu
bringen denn es gab keine zivilisten auf
der insel
die sowjetunion greift nicht an und 2002
wird auf der insel die letzte
militärische übung abgehalten
[Musik]
heute ist das ehemalige sperrgebiet ein
nationalpark und über die hälfte der
insel für die öffentlichkeit zugänglich
jost vom bergbau und der armee
gezeichnet überall einschusslöcher hier
war kein schon maßlos für so eine kleine
insel im nirgendwo
[Musik]
ostengland an der küste von suffolk
reihen sich ungewöhnliche gebäude
aneinander
seltsame fundamente und pagoden ähnliche
strukturen
es ist sehr abgelegen und vom festland
durch einen fluss getrennt
und doch stehen hier diese bauten
und von innen sind diese ruinen noch
rätselhafter
[Musik]
in seite barry gebäude wirken wie
verlassene fabriken es gibt eine menge
metallschrott und veraltete maschinen
ziemlich sicher war das was hier vor
sich ging geheim streng geheim
man wird immer noch davor gewarnt die
wege nicht zu verlassen
sonst fliegt man in die luft
wofür wurden die zerfallen gebäude und
asiatisch anmutenden pagoden genutzt und
warum ist es hier so gefährlich
die lage und der zerstörungsgrad des
gebäudekomplexes
klassen reichlich fragen auf
was war da los
[Musik]
1913 kurz vor dem ersten weltkrieg
das britische kriegsministerium er wird
ein großes gelände nahe eines kleinen
ortes in suffolk hier sollen die
modernsten kriegswaffen systeme
entwickelt werden
[Musik]
in dieser ecke von england er wurde mit
fliegerbomben experimentiert
könnte also sagen dass an diesem strand
die militärische luftfahrt anfing
es ging darum die militärtechnik
weiterzuentwickeln
und hier enorm es war man ganz vorn mit
dabei
[Musik]
im ersten weltkrieg wurden die gerade
erfundenen flugzeuge bereits eingesetzt
aber die technik war noch sehr
rudimentär die bomben wurden einfach aus
dem cockpit geworfen
man hatte keine ahnung was genau nach
einem bombenabwurf passiert und das
wurde in ordnung aufgezeichnet und
analysiert
[Musik]
nach und nach wird opferten es zum
wichtigsten militärischen testgebiet für
die royal air force
ihr arbeitet unter anderem der
schottische physiker robert watson rott
der sich 1919 das verfahren zur ortung
von objekten mittels radiowellen also
das radar patentieren lässt
1935 gelingt es ihm so anfliegende
bomber per radar zu entdecken was
großbritannien während des zweiten
weltkriegs große dienste leistet
die ära des kalten kriegs bringt dann
neue herausforderungen
während des zweiten weltkriegs hatten
die usa und großbritannien in der waffen
entwicklung eng zusammengearbeitet
das hörte nach 1945 schlagartig auf und
großbritannien arbeitete an eigenen
waffensystemen darunter auch atomwaffen
die atomwaffenproduktion im westen läuft
auf hochtouren
1949 ist der kalte krieg schon in vollem
gange
die briten waren teil des nuklearen
wettrüstens und of hotness wurde zur
forschungsanstalt für atomwaffen
eine atombombe darf auf keinen fall aus
versehen hochgehen weder auf dem weg
zwischen fabrik und flugzeug noch im
flugzeug auf dem weg zum ziel oder zum
falschen zeitpunkt nach dem abwurf
um alters auszuschließen bedarf es
vielfältiger tests und genau daran wurde
hier mit nachdruck gearbeitet und
experimentiert
was waren das für experimente
wenn klar wird es erklären
zunächst wurden die bomben vibrationen
ausgesetzt wie in flugzeugen oder
transportfahrzeugen
später kamen noch stoßwellen g-kräfte
luftfeuchtigkeit und extreme
temperaturen dazu
jedes labor war für einen anderen
störfaktor ausgelegt
das hier war die sogenannte einschlag
einheit mit tests unter besonders
extremen bedingungen
hier wurden alle möglichen nuklearwaffen
getestet und die extra dicken betonwände
waren so designt dass der eigentliche
einschlag der atombombe nachgestellt
werden konnte
aber die spannendsten objekte waren
besonders weit entfernt die pagoden
sie sind noch heute das wahrzeichen der
anlage
sie haben was von antiken tempeln die
säulen tragen eine flache pyramide und
dann sieht man diese kreuzförmigen
markierungen an den wänden wie eisen
spannen
[Musik]
all das unterliegt im kalten krieg
strengster geheimhaltung
während der späten 50er anfang der 60er
jahre war die anspannung im kalten krieg
vielleicht auf dem höhepunkt
in dieser zeit sollen es unter ständiger
beobachtung durch die sowjetunion
gestanden haben weshalb die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen immer weiter
erhöht worden
die bauweise der anlage war zwar sehr
ungewöhnlich erfüllte dabei aber einen
ganz bestimmten zweck es ging darum die
funktionsweise von waffen und
explosionen zu erforschen
es war so angelegt dass bei sprengung
der säulen das dach herab sauste und die
explosion und trümmer unter sich begrub
was dort sonst noch erforscht wurde ist
zum großen teil immer noch unter
verschluss
ironischerweise trägt er erfolgte
einrichtung wesentlich zu seinem
untergang bei die usa sind so
beeindruckt dass sie das gemeinsame
rüstungsprogramm mit großbritannien
wieder aufnehmen
[Musik]
die anlage für das britische
atomwaffentest programm wurde nicht
länger benötigt als die briten anfingen
in sachen nuklearwaffen mit den usa
zusammenzuarbeiten
das ist bis heute so
1987 das militärgelände von agnes wird
endgültig aufgegeben
heute ist es ein naturschutzgebiet
aber seine vergangenheit hat ein
gefährliches erbe hinterlassen
auch das soll man nach so vielen
jahrzehnten kann man immer noch nicht
sicher sein dass alle sprengkörper
gefunden und entschärft wurden
es ist praktisch unmöglich das gesamte
gelände vollständig zu säubern
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen bauten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie könnten von krieg
und terror von erfindergeist und
menschlichem streben nach fortschritt
[Musik]